to be here for vacuum ACI seminar in
this building with so many friends and
former colleagues future colleagues and
future friends this is a really nice
awesome hot-off-the-press
result you know that I'm still kind of
emailing back and forth with my student
about so be patient and ask me questions
probably at the end just oh credits this
is mostly work led by my PhD student
Maurice at Cornell Tech with some other
great collaborators including Xiao and
including some faculty here even like
Jeff Hancock and my commission Google
but just a disclaimer this is a Cornell
talk I'm wearing my Cornell hat not
physically but metaphorically not about
Google don't represent Google in any way
here all right good
trust let me try this again in a more
John Oliver way trust that was my my
best British accent Trust is why we can
go 5,000 miles and stay with someone we
have never met before in their house
trust is also why you can leave food and
the gates of frigerator and hope that is
not taken away and eaten by somebody
else
Trust is why you can book speakers
inviting hundreds of people to see them
and know that they show up for the talk
and Trust is also why we can eat at
restaurants some of the faculty might
remember this in their students I don't
know Seinfeld
so Trust is often defined as the
willingness to take risk make yourself
vulnerable to others with expectation of
getting some future reward Trust is
fundamental to almost everything we do
every day our interactions our
transactions our relationships but not
only those trust is also important for
our society and our economy to function
we just very simple
institutions and organizations and we do
that every day in Western societies more
often more likely than others in
multiple ways and others which ask the
government to mostly act on our in our
best interest we trust corporations for
example banks with our money or let's
say certain companies we trust the media
to reflect to us how a society is
functioning or not we'll come back to
the media in a second all together the
trust relationships are fundamental to
the stability of our society in our
democracy but how we trust each other
has also shifted so our social
structures and interaction shifted from
the interpersonal face-to-face
communities to social and online media's
where our trust our informational
assumptions our interactions or trust
decisions are informed governed and are
sometimes increasingly supported by
technology and AI so the decision to
trust who moves to be online and our
interactions have moved online as well
so what happens to trust in these
settings has been the topic of research
that my group has been looking at the
last few years so what happens it's new
information ecosystem where our
interactions are supported by algorithms
and AI and not in face-to-face setting
and notice that I'm talking about not
trust in technology but trust how we
trust each other through technology
which is a slightly different topic so
here's the outline for this talk one
thread of the talk will be looking at
trust in media and
[Music]
look at how in I'm gonna describe an
online experiment on how Trust in media
is impacted by our partisan evaluations
of both sources and headline content
this is one experiment the other thread
looks at trust in interpersonal settings
and I'm going to introduce a new topic
that a new concept that we call AI
immediate communication which kind of
represents the fact that a lot of our
communication are not necessarily
transmitted by computers but also
optimized in some way or generated by
algorithms and machines to get some kind
of outcome and we'll look at an online
experiment that talks about trust and
investigates were happy to trust in
those settings so these are two on an
experiment and at the end I'm going to
talk about a few ways that we can think
about this problem as HCI researchers
I'm not going to talk about today other
work at the lab is Michael mentioned we
do very different kinds of work not just
online experiments for example recent
tools to support journalists in battling
visual misinformation it's more like an
HDI systems project we have project on
looking at misinformation targeted at
political candidates and and so forth
but today mostly online experiment work
so trust in media I already start with
the motivation but just to expand a
little bit specifically on media our
information the basis of our reality of
political reality or social reality is
based a lot on our media consumption in
that media consumption is increasingly
served via algorithmically curated feeds
whether it's recommendation systems
whether it's news feeds like Facebook
and others and interesting question what
happens to trust in the media musician
and the information that they serve in
those settings trust in media and
journalism is the foundation of the
democracy and the purpose of journalism
is to make us informed so we can be free
self-governing so this is an important
area to study at the same time we also
know that media is increasingly under
attack if you've been following the news
increasingly seen as partisan and
manipulated in various ways with
consequences we know that Americans
currently do not trust the media they
have very low levels of trust
increasingly observed this is from the
Edelman Trust Barometer and we also know
that it's very partisan why people trust
the media sources that align with their
views and distrust the others so this
partisanship was one of the key things
that we want to focus on to see how
people evaluate it in online settings in
particular we wanted to ask how the
evaluation of the news headlines that we
encountered in our feeds might be
impacted by how we align ourselves with
the source versus how we align yourself
with what they report so to give an
example if you're conservative and maybe
you have a preference for fox news and
you see a fox news headline that said
that the majority of american now
support the impeachment process are you
gonna say get out of here i don't
believe that because you have some kind
of bias advice towards accepting that
kind of news are we gonna believe fox
news because they align with the view
and say if fox news reports that that
must be correct compared to the same
headline for example served by the new
york times so you already probably guess
that they're few factors that may impact
this evaluation one of them is source
credibility so how much i trust the
source how much I trust the expertise
how much they aligned with my goals and
my views will impact how I trust the
information they report another factor
of course is motivated reasoning right
the idea sometimes called Direction
directionally motivated reasoning that
seeks us to look for information I've
reinforced our existing views
confirmation bias is one of the
mechanisms that it's involved with
motivated reasoning and that means that
people accept things along with the view
and tend to reject
new information that does not align with
their world views and experiences and
finally another thing that can happen
especially when you're doing online
experiment to ask people about their
views is what is called expressive or
sometimes motivated responding the idea
there is that when individual is
presented with information that is on
against their worldview they might know
the right answer but still be expressive
and report the wrong answer to you to
the experimenter so this happened
famously when Republicans were asked
about inauguration photos so they were
shown side by side clearly labeled
photos from the Obama and Trump
inauguration you've seen those you know
that Obama's was clearly better attended
and yet the Republican responded in
higher numbers tended to say that trance
was better attended okay so now we can
ask a little bit more detailed research
question which is how would the
evaluation of views change in the
response to the different sources and
the different media sources in
particular what is the relative impact
of how you trust the source with versus
how you align yourself with the headline
in the second part we're not going to
talk about is whether we can actually
find evidence that people are doing this
expressive responding when we do this
study so the way we did that is an
online experiment as I mentioned in in
the experiment we randomly assigned
headlines that claims that we chose
specifically for the study and sources
we chose both of them had leaning right
or left and I'll show you how we did it
in a second in fact this is the most
important one method slide that should
pay attention to we took a bunch of
headlines and sometimes we showed a
left-leaning headline with from a
left-leaning source like the New York
Times
sometimes we show that same headline as
it was coming as if it was coming from a
right-leaning source
and the opposite right we took
right-leaning headline and sometimes we
showed up with a left-leaning source and
sometimes with the right-wing source
okay that's that was the basic seller
actually going to show you one more
slide that you need to pay attention to
and then a bunch of other at more
detailed information we basically for
every one of those headlines we ask
people if they think the claim in the
headline was true or false you can ask
me later a lot of details of how we
selected this question and whether or
not we wanted the scale or just drew a
force but we ended up with with this for
this study yeah yeah great I'll talk
about the headline selection in a second
the answer is yes for the experiment yes
there were all things that we valid that
is true whatever that means so here's
how we selected the claims in particular
we want to claim that our representative
of what people might encounter in their
everyday news consumption we wanted
things that were factual that people can
actually say somebody can actually say
whether they're true or not true we
wanted things that were partisan that
people supported us liberal or
conservative views and we wanted things
that are not easily marked as true right
so it's not Trump it's the president
it's States but things that are a little
harder to guess for any any person I
don't have time to go all the details of
how we did this if you a quick reader
you can get an idea but just to say that
we we that is Maurice that graduate
student went through a long process of
data collection a notation at the end of
which we had ten headlines that we valid
it was right-leaning and ten that we
evaluated as left-leaning
or we based on our variation were right
meaning with claims that we valid is
true but also verified that were hard to
to know whether the true or not by
people on Mechanical Turk so and these
are the two examples like you've seen
before for sources we wanted to have
sources that are widely recognized
the organization and notice when I say
media and not necessarily journalistic
organizations and you see in a second
and we also wanted sources that are
perceived by the public as leaning one
way and biased in some way partisan or
other yes we wanted to we made sure that
we got wants based on previous studies
were kind of you know well if they had
to be recognizable enough we couldn't go
to the really far end of the bias but as
you can see we show things that are
quite different
yeah we try to go as far as far as we
can but make sure that we have things
that are recognizable so it doesn't
leave us with a lot of choice after we
cover these six so were hard to justify
adding anyone anyone else to this list
so CNA and half for the New York Times
versus Fox News The Drudge Report in and
Breitbart are kind of seen as opposite
scales by the public and are widely
recognized by studies done they were
fairly quickly they're not seen as the
certainty equivalent how there's they
seem to others from the right on the
left so they're not that far off in
terms of biased perception and I'm not
this is not a qualitative comment about
how biased they are or not but yeah I
mean again there was no perfect choice
that may have been a little differences
between them and how they lean but and
we also have I don't have it here today
but we have an analysis of pair one of
these stories I'm gonna aggravate this
but we can talk later about how they
actually differed between them so here's
how the experiment was set up as I
mentioned we had 20 claims left leaning
in blue and writing in in in
red for each participant that came into
the online experiment we matched a
random liberal claim with the liberal
source like it described before and then
did a right-leaning claim with a
right-leaning source and then we mix it
up so each of then star for these
headlines that we asked them then
whether they were they thought it was
true or not
now if we just did this for the purpose
of the experiment would have been pretty
obvious
so we also mix it up to hide the true
aim of the study we also show them 12
other headlines I'm not going to talk
about how they're so like this I'm just
going to mention the two of them the
black ones for actual fake news things
so as they go through the headlines they
mark things that are true false oh
they'll find things that were pretty
clearly false right so they didn't have
to force himself to mark things as false
otherwise we also asked them about their
political leanings and we use very
various measures to do that for example
who they voted for would identify where
they would have fought before and others
the analysis results are pretty much the
same for each of these measures we asked
them about trust recognition of the
media sources that we used and others
and also we got some demographic
information although that was very
limited given that we use Mechanical
Turk the spread there was not that great
okay so we launched the study on
Mechanical Turk got a lot of people to
rate our headlines and let's look at
some of the results actually before we
look at them let's see what people think
might have more impact it was it the
source the people believe the source of
the language of you so if the
conservative and Fox News they'll
believe anything that they say or was it
the headlines the headline claims were
they aligned with the claim it didn't
matter who reported it then they saw
they thought it was not true so who
thinks the source had more impact and
who think the headline alignment had
more intact all right let's see let's
see what happened you can change your
mind many shots okay
what did you ask them if you just say
yeah or anything else just say it was
true for and then we can see for each
what we did it's a great show in a
second we have you get it for for each
supers or for each in fact for each
meaning of each match of source and
source leaning and person leaning we
could see how many times they go yeah
yeah yeah we this is the second right
we'll see the effect of bias but we're
not going to measure directly ask about
the bias yeah yeah what's the connection
between the true or false election that
people were asked to make when how
you're reading the trust question yeah
so yeah from the connection inside
that's right
so unless I'm gonna say that this is a
measure of trust right in specially in
the sources so we'll see if that's
that's what's happening here
so what happens with the this is the
source effect so when we see here at the
top for example these are all the
left-leaning participants and how much
they trusted the two dots or how much
they on average trusted how many times
they saw a claim that was from left
sorry the source is left-leaning right
and the the blue points is how much time
the participants on the right and on the
Left chose to believe headlines that
were associated with that the
left-leaning source right so for example
the right blue dot on the top line is 56
percent of the time were a left-leaning
participant so headline coming from a
left-leaning source they marked it as
true right and you can see that there's
only a little bit of difference here
between the participant on the right and
on the left were the right ending
participant believed the left-leaning
sources 53 percent of the time
that's like the whole statement I did
not disagree only the fortunate or
reading so we got from each
participant's yep we did not give them a
bamboo that's why we give them the to
clearly false things so what we didn't
we didn't want to say anything about
what proportion of them are for some joy
that's yes so they were accurate
there will be hundred because they read
it we only looking at the four things
that we valid that's true and that's the
only thing that momentum showing here so
if they were accurate people before all
the way to that to the end so they could
have seen the fake news articles the
very first and that would have that
could have buyers their view of the next
ones upload it could be but I don't know
what the bottom so this is for the bike
lending socio there's a slightly
different effect were the right cleaning
participants believed it fifty six
percent of the time right so when
something came from a right leaning
sourcing only 47 percent of the time
were left leaning participants so that
they believed those sidelines so there
was some effective source and you'll
notice and not come back to the ended
that that effect was mostly generated by
the left-leaning participants but the
chief did the most frightening purchase
maybe not almost shift to the response
to source at all yeah I don't know I
said to maybe they're rounding rounding
error the effect of the claim was a lot
more dramatic and at least you'll notice
that again you'll notice that this was
mostly for the left-leaning participants
in I'll come back to that again so the
left naming participant when they saw a
claim that the line with their views
they believe it a lot more
and when they saw a claim that was not
they believed it a lot less the right
leaning person who did not have a
similar shift so it was a regression
again I said that I was still a this
initial analysis we're still analyzing
some data but we could run a regression
to predict the true or false results and
can see that seven percent are if you
have an alliance or seven percent more
likely to think something is true but in
particular if you have a claim that's
aligned with you you're fifteen percent
more likely to believe that claim yep
right so definitely so we need I don't
have all the results is because we want
to make sure we do properly their war
interactions in fact the interactions
are we're also dependent on the source
because not all the sources were treated
in the same way so The Drudge Report is
you can imagine was a little different
than Fox News in key way so I don't have
the full resort sitting probably need to
collect more data but this trend has
been very similar we now run this
experiment or similar one about three
times with very similar results every
single time regardless of the new
sources we use regardless of their
claims very similar seeing just that it
seems like it is an interaction right it
seems like the right leading people
attended to the claim and the left
leading people attended to the source no
I don't think that that's I don't know
that we're seeing we haven't seen that
in the other studies that we read so I
don't think that that's what's happening
that is the here it's the claim right
okay so the participant out of the dots
and so when they see a left-leaning
claim this is how the participant
reality I'm gonna steal your writing
misinterprets
but there was definitely difference in
how they reacted but not not that so I
think we have from the studies that
we've done the multiple studies and this
other just presented there is a strong
evidence for motivated reasoning that
the claim is a lot stronger when you see
something in your feed even if you're
lying with the source the the claim
review will be a stronger force in this
evaluation the second thing is that
surprising asymmetry that we found
between the left and right wing and
again it wasn't as strong and the other
studies that that we've done and I'm not
doing it today but there was always a
stronger reaction from the left-leaning
participants and from the right leaning
once it I don't know if I can explain
but a couple of reasons for that maybe
one is the type of sources that we
picked for the experiments and to the
the fact that we have a mostly right
leaning government right now image might
cause different types of responses with
different participants but that's
something that we try to investigate
further I didn't discuss the expressive
responding part where people know the
right answer but say what they really
want to be true we have some evidence
that that's happening but inconclusive I
would say this at this point so the next
thing we want to do is so they do this
right of this but then we didn't see a
lot of things beyond the main effects
things like you four words that you have
to have some stuff known to be true to
get people to believe the stuff that's
yeah well we'll so we haven't evaluated
that so the idea right so this is
something that appears on the feed so
you don't necessarily go to the info war
website and consume everything that they
have so there's no reputation and effect
there about the interesting other
question yeah you really primed people
to be thinking about the veracity
everything is like is this one true is
this one true is this one true and I'm
wondering if that were not as primed or
a salient what the effects would be
right do you think like my assumption is
that would be far weaker if I weren't
trying to sniff out fake news from my
media and scrolling through stuff I read
maybe yeah in fact the Chronicle is I
think there's other the more perhaps
significant threat to ecological ability
is the fact that most of these
newspapers will report headlines that
are aligned or at least report claims in
a way that the ears aligned with their
views all right so when Fox News for
example did post the 51% of Americans
support the impeachment process it was a
big deal people said I can't believe Fox
News did that so it doesn't happen often
and then you might ask you know so what
does this mean for how people really
evaluate so in another yeah they really
strongly in fact in the second study
I'll show in a different area we're
gonna talk about the mechanisms that do
trigger this evaluation right and
thought and and how would they impact
the results so that definitely can
happen as well so we specifically wanted
to put people in that situation so we
can evaluate the effect of source versus
headline claim alignment but the
ecological validity is therefore I think
that I think you could teach us
something about the evolution works in
the real world but in a specific
scenario where we put in cognitive
effort and processing they're gonna be
sniffing around for like what them
nation is listed right yeah so I don't
know how that would swing the results
but see the other people would get sort
of a little bit more attuned to what
might be happening yeah we were
imagining and we asked them debrief
questions to Sage they were I think they
study yeah yeah we lose the case but
yeah it's a good consistently low in
every single version of that exponent
that we run very similar overall scale
yeah so that's really it's a newer past
reporting something Limor all evaluated
by liberals or conservatives right that
we didn't quite have enough data in this
study to do this this level of analysis
but it's an interesting I think question
we wonder last question for an hour then
it seems like different conversations
about trust what it is in terms of the
drivers of behavior were there any other
assumptions you were trying to make on
what trust I loves people to do like
selection of a story before you read
them
yeah determining whether a fact is a
fact or not after you
in your case it seems like you're asking
people to say whether they believe the
source saying this is true or false and
it actually happened or not it seems
like that is your metric for going
backwards into trust yeah
did you have any other considerations or
how you will determine trust other than
this true/false thing no in fact we
wanted to kind of factor away everything
else because we thought that this is how
people encounter most of information so
you know we didn't talk about you know
how you select your exposure how you
moderate it how you valued you know any
anything like that was kind of factored
out mostly so that's a yeah very narrow
trust question were asking here let me
just quickly say there are other things
that you can ask about for example what
kind of signals they see on the news
article and in terms of previous
interactions so here we have an
experiment where we told them that this
piece of content was rated by people
mostly Democratic and they mostly
thought it was true and then we asked
them how that changes or how they
evaluate a claim based on that this is
common in some online feeds but I'm not
going to get into that today in
particular I think it's interesting to
continue to consider the how this
relates to the filter bubble right so
the idea of a filter bubble that we can
see the viewpoints of people are
different than us but if you don't trust
those viewpoints but you can put all the
Fox News you want in my feed or all the
headlines the counter my confirm my bias
in my feed but it'll probably just go
cause a backfire effect so how do we
change that so we can trust the other
side and what their shares and the
claims that we make is an interesting
and important question okay moe let me
move into the interpersonal trust aspect
of the talk you know try to do it more
quickly there's also a nice set up a
online experiment and here we asked
about
how we trust each other so not Mindy
organization of the information we
provide but literally how we trust each
other and this was motivated by as I
mentioned before what the trends that we
see in computer mediated communication
that was traditionally the idea of the
sender composes some message and
transmit this to the receiver given the
channel so they craft the message to
this channel whether it's text or video
or whatever that is
but the receiver evaluates it completely
knowing that that it was generated by
the sender with a I increasingly we have
communication channels for the agent the
AI agent participates in the
communication in an active way suggest
edits modifications we have generates
the entire communication on our behalf
we have a paper with Jeff and Karen Levy
at Cornell what we call this a IMC we
talk about interpersonal communication
that in the increasingly optimized
augmentation generated by algorithms to
get specific outcomes from the receiver
let me give you some examples of how
this exists today everybody here uses
Gmail
I'm guessing and Gmail gives you now
what we call smart replies this is a
response for me to my student
dissertation proposal I don't think I
used that one in this case LinkedIn will
generate an automatic summary from your
resume online a more involved way Google
duplex can have entire conversations on
your behalf that will then project on
how you are seen by that entity or
business and so just some current-day
examples in the future we may have AI
that can make your face more trustworthy
in online or offline settings we can
have you know AI the pic dnews were from
Berkeley dancing like a pro or lifting
weights that you can't otherwise do in
world settings so and or just simply
optimize your message for maximum
persuasion for each
individual you're communicating with so
with this entire future of AI NC we
asked a very simple question which is
how would people evaluate others
differently if they know that AI involve
involved in particular in profile
creation so when we create online
profiles there are a number of theories
that may predict that the outcome of
such involvement I'll go over this
quickly you have the pointers
it could be not changing at all because
people will not mind it at all it could
be seen as more trustworthy when AI or
computer generates your profile because
yeah there is no gorge Mystics of
computers cannot lie or computers are
good at producing the correct
information and it could be less
trustworthy for example because there is
more and certainly there's something in
the middle now between the human
actually describing themself and you're
reading that description so concretely
we use the Airbnb in the research
contrast context both because it's a
kind of high stake trust situation but
also because we had a lot of great data
about trustworthiness of hosts from
previous studies that we run in my lab
by my students show and we asked
participants here or the question was
how will potential guests evaluate hosts
differently if they think a I was
involved in authoring the profile okay
just like that shown before so in this
online experiment we showed people text
descriptions of Airbnb hosts and we
asked them to rate them for
trustworthiness and sometimes we had
those profiles show as automatically
generated by computers we didn't like
the way to use the term AI in the study
because it's kind of loaded socially and
people already have some negative
interactions to it so we said generate
by computer so what is something like
that that was more neutral perhaps in
fact we showed them this is what we
showed them that was happening
kind of that was the deception in the
study we said of people who put in the
face of professor and we get a general
profile everybody believed that
manipulation would pretty sure people
think that AI is capable of doing lists
or computers are doing this in reality
importantly we used only profitable
actually written by hosts so here is the
first experiment that we did we took ten
profiles that were slightly different in
how trustworthy they had base simple
previous studies and we asked people in
the control condition we said this is
these are all written there will be
regular profiles please write them for
trustworthiness and then in the
treatment we asked we told them these
were all written by AI I think we had
some cover story or for developing a new
system and tell us what you think how
trustworthy the horse the host it's for
this study so the task was to evaluate
the trustworthiness of the host so we
ran on the Camco Turk getting ratings so
here's the rating that we got for the
control group so this is regular human
profiles you can see that they varied in
trustworthiness really accurately
matching what we expected their high
trustfulness lower trustworthiness users
so here every column is a one of the
hosts and this is the average
trustworthiness ratings right so the
five ones on the Left were more trusted
than the five on the right and then we
now we can see for the same profits what
happened when they were evaluated as AI
everything profiles okay who thinks they
were trusted more when AI did profiles
which now will you afraid of me who
thinks AI professor who trusted more
than human for the same professor when
people thought they were written by AI
were trusted more who thinks were
trusted less all right good right yeah
it called the false selection because
who actually trusted the same
they're absolutely no difference this is
tracking very closely every single
profile the rating but you know this is
we still have time in the talk and I
wouldn't be showing you this today this
was the only resort that we had so we
had two other experiments actually I'm
gonna tell you about the first one
showed no effect but we thought it may
have been no effect because all the
profits were the same kind and we said
we were wondering what happens if we mix
them up in various ways
so now we will have a setup where we
have profits that are sometimes AI
written and sometimes hosts written yeah
do you think this is written by nai no
no well read the paper for details but
the main question was devaluing the
trustworthiness of the hosts directly so
the benevolence integrity there's a firm
of a mire that we use to asked about the
trustworthiness and we also asked how
much they think it's a I'll come back to
that later but not you know all the
cases I'll show it in second so in this
experiment or exam we took the same
profiles and we just so showed an
interface we sometimes when we told them
some of those were written by us and
some of those was written by AI but I'm
not going to tell you about experiment 2
I'm going to tell you about experiment 3
where we had 30 profiles that were
pre-tested of how much people think they
are written by AI or written by a host
so to do that we had a pretest where we
took professor who kind of average
trustworthiness and we asked people if
they think that this was written by
human or between by AI okay so here's an
example here's a profile that people
mostly thought were written by AI hello
I'm Sebastian originally from Germany
and this was a profile that people
usually thought it was written by human
let me open with a huge hello to
everyone reading this right so it was
very clean very strong effect to come
back to this
later of what people thought was AI or
not then again reminder everything here
written by humans right no way I was
hurt in the making of this research so
okay from this for each participant we
chose five of each randomly and then
randomly shown them in random order and
we had a few conditions and one of them
again we told them these were all
written by hosts in the second one we
told them again this was mixed with some
of them written by her some by AI and in
the third we actually labeled goes that
word that looks more like AI we actually
put generated profile on them and the
other ones we put human or whatever we
didn't put any information all right so
let's see what happened so first of all
this is the condition where people
thought all these profiles were human as
you can see the profiles that we pre
labeled as looking like AI were actually
more trustworthy in these settings so
right so now we have the profit that we
know look like yeah if we ask people the
question but the participant thought is
these were all human so they were rated
as more trustworthy this is what
happened when we we told them that the
professor mixed we can be either AI or
human but we didn't label them so they
didn't know which one is which in this
case we actually saw that everything
that we thought looked more like AI
indeed suffered the drop in
trustworthiness and the humans did not
in fact be humans may have had a little
increase in that setting so things that
look like humans that we knew look like
he was right remember they were not
labeled or anything when we had a label
condition so now that this is the same
profiles that look like a ient or look
like humans that we actually labeled as
computer-generated or not and the
computer generated profits got even more
of a drop in trustworthiness compared to
the humans interestingly if we argue get
that in a different condition in explain
we actually ask people
excu ask we ask people how they I think
they think the profiles now and we could
see that the mere suspicion of that
something was written by a over the
cause the drop in the trustworthiness
ratings pretty significant one too until
when they were pretty sure that
something is was they I generated it was
already leveled bottom the bottom of
trustworthiness course so no effect on
rating except when this information was
mixed so we had the consistently in both
experiment to and the various condition
of three that we saw that they would
drop interest was for things that looked
like a guy and could we ask the question
before I think the the LM the
elaboration likelihood model can help
explain this this is also what happened
in the previous study perhaps right when
we ask people to kind of to make that AI
more salient it caused him to think
about this more and therefore they
shifted in their scores more when AI was
brought to the front that may have led
them to participate in a more careful
evaluation right so more salient
iteration may be central route that can
be called inulin and therefore reduce
the scores here so for example super
only thirty would like say well I don't
trust them because they didn't bother to
write a profile it was about the honest
signal that I took the time to actually
construct something and not about the
existence of the AI itself being the
problem there's this other possible
explanation that it is something about
like oh I don't trust it because it
wasn't vetted or something like this
those mechanisms there's something
learning I think like like the
warranting or the difficulty to fake
this up we've gone the other way but in
fact I think that that's what what's
going on here I think what was going on
is
it was not liberation of the AI but it
was the volition of people because we
asked him what the person might say it
was revelation of a person using the AI
[Music]
even if I'm evaluating the person am i
evaluating that they didn't bother to
write a profile so they're not
trustworthy right it would be like a
person on Twitter was just an egg all
right
or is it that because it was generated
by an ad I it may be inaccurate right
yeah so I'm not doing in here the paper
discusses a little bit because we also
had an open-ended response for this and
from what we have seen there it's more
of the former right so this is the the
laziness I don't think that that word
was used but the idea of why would if I
if it's mixed right why would they have
to use this was interesting I think
interesting finding for example here's a
the AI MC but we see in fact recently in
the last few weeks I think Apple
launched the fixing of the gays when you
are we're having a video conference
right they fix your eyeballs to look at
the participant which will have obvious
effect also on the people not using it
because they might seem as less
trustworthy right or obvious evaluate or
sorry of different evaluation of the
people are actually looking at you when
they talk and not fixed by AI because
people were not think that they're using
AI to fix it okay so I think this is
interesting question regardless of how
people what think about the artificial
intelligence here so in fact the fact
that this the effect only happens when
the mixed when there's a mixed
environment we thought was interesting
and I think is relevant for the other
cases as well so we gave it a name as
you mentioned before we called it the
replicant effect or in the world that's
populated by both droids and humans the
even the slight suspicion that something
is a droid will cause a significant drop
in trustworthiness evaluation
then I think I don't want to say
anything about but the paper provides a
little bit of details and something we
want to do in future studies is there
was a strong kind of a folk theory of
what is written by AI and what is not
which was funny because as I said
everything was human and also funny
because AI can actually be written to
optimize on on this classification and
make itself seem like it was not written
by AI so alright I think there's a very
interesting set of questions one can ask
in this new world of ANC we started with
kind of representation and how
expectations shift when we have AI
mediation in communication including
lasting effect it might have on how we
trust each other but also has
interesting questions on language use
for example how suggested replies or
other kinds of tools like that will
affect our communication effectiveness
you've probably already seen all of you
have seen how positive the Google smart
replies are which may shift not only how
we correspond using those replies but
our expectations from conversation from
everyone else so and also communication
outcomes and there's some work coming
out from Cornell just how Einstein and
Marty young show that communication
blame is works differently when we have
AI involved in communication and finally
a lot of interesting policy and ethical
questions on where we should disclose or
not disclose the use of AI and how we
should talk about what it optimizes for
but I wanna in fact we have a little
paper I just put on yesterday sorry for
that
a IMC paper is a preprint of an upcoming
paper where we provide a lot of what we
think are interesting questions going
forward in that area this is with Jeff
and Karen let me go back to trust so we
can have some finishing words so I've
shown kind of
glanced over but a few different
versions of trust in how it happens in
our online environments in one part I
show how partisan tendencies impact our
evaluation of content in our shared fact
base and another one I showed how the AI
involvement in Conte generation brings
new challenges in our evaluation of
trustworthiness of others online these
trends will continue
we have increasingly partisan content
fake or otherwise that will push us to
increasingly two silos of anger and
distrust online we have the more
exposure that we have to this chain the
more mistrust it would just keep
escalating right so everything that we
see online we're not gonna believe it
we're gonna reject it we're gonna make
its worse make it worse for the next
generation of content we value it all
the way to of course deep fakes that
will undermine any trust we might have
in content text image video inter
personal or otherwise so when this
happens and we need to think about ways
to not let it happen this happens it
might undermine the trust that we have
in each other the trust that we have in
other forms of society that lets us
function on a daily basis in fact Neal
Stephenson's for the recent novel novel
imagines dystopian but not far-fetched
future in which there is a lot of
disinformation and if you read it in the
book there is a group that pulls the
massive hoax that meant to convince the
world that mob were just wiped by a
nuclear explosion minuta and the the
thing what really happened is that the
hoax was set up by people who wanted to
cause enough panic for society to
reconsider the basic elements of our
information ecosystem works or in the
internet or the miasma it's called in
the book that allowed the hoax to happen
right so they do this and I think to
make us reconsider our basic assumptions
of the Internet not a spoiler by the way
this is in page 200 out of 800 pages of
the book I'm still powering through it
and indeed there is no easy solution for
trusts trustees of course is the HDI
people who recognize a wicked problem
one that has no obvious solution or
stopping condition no and will take
multiple stakeholders - and for many
disciplines to address right so we need
the technologists we need behavior
started with indication we need policy
we need media and journalism in other
words a perfect problem for HCI scholars
some of the things that we can do is
continue to do empirical research both
understanding misinformation but also
our trust is created and hindered and
undermined online the second is to think
about new systems and infrastructure
that can promote and maintain the
trustworthy sources and credible sources
is in itself an interesting and an
important question right so how do we
identify those but also how do we
promote those and finally come up with a
policies and ethical and regulatory
framework that can support these systems
to exist given what we know about trust
I think we still have time for a few
questions leave you with my Twitter
handle
and a lovely photo of the Cornell Tech
campus at night thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
yes a great question so let me maybe
rephrase the question is about whether
we can somehow give some proven ins to a
claim that will help show how the
assumptions are different than mine and
therefore help me reflect on the in the
outcome in a different way but it's
obviously hard to do for any a new
consumer application or things that
people use an ongoing basis so that's
that's one challenge the second it's
this builds on such a significant
background that is hard to maybe think
about the technologies here right so
it's hard to tweak out for any headline
and claim your money counter online
because such embedded in your worldview
in so many ways and in your network so
I'm guessing it would be hard to do
interesting to see what the mini version
of that might entail on how that we
think but I don't know if you have ideas
I'll be happy to hear what
it's a lot yeah so and how far you need
to go right so yeah that's good
it's possible and you cannot do it
enough yeah at the end of you said a few
times that they were actually inhuman
that yeah yeah great so the questions
were properly we use could it's possible
they were written by some by non-human
unlikely based on our evaluation I we
saw more definitely all the profiles we
use and everything we draw out we drew
from and I don't think it was likely
what is likely an interesting for future
study is to see what people if people
react the same way if we told them not
that than AI as written is but another
human has written this for their for the
host and how that will change I think
that may have similar effects yes didn't
look this way in your in your first
study you asked disclose left-leaning
all right leaning as part of their
variable into the into the study it was
that an equivalent you did for the
second study in terms of the
participants active you to a I it said
oh yeah we in the second study we did
yes we measured AI attitudes and we also
measured general trust attitude so
generalize trust measures and there was
definitely there were two things I can
say about this is so thing about people
generalize trust tendency so how
generally how people trust others in
society controlling for that was the
same as controlling for the baseline of
how different people believe different
profiles and didn't have any effect the
AI ness or the AI attitude I don't think
had a lot of impact on if I remember
correctly but I can check on the actual
results of human livers to say I trust
when I say
take the trouble to write it yeah so now
I know the other side means things that
oh this guy picked that option to the
Lord I know people don't use our options
yeah
so now if I took that study if I was a
participant on M Kirk and I had this
sort of conflicting experience on how my
I am engaging with a is it also impacts
my own I could you do a I become more
skeptical than maybe otherwise well I
think that's a whether it's a digital
body I or that it's a person use of AI I
think that has I think definitely the
gmail question is fascinating right so
the more now that I get everybody here
probably in this room you go back today
and somebody will fly with great idea
let's do it
you'll be like wait a second do they
just press the button and it will cause
it to reevaluate your work to evaluate
them in a different light so I think
it's a fascinating question
[Applause]